[APPLAUSE]
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: All right,
good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for
joining the session.
So, I'm Mo.
I'm the business development
manager covering the Middle
East, North Africa, and Turkey.
It's a pleasure to be here with
this amazing set of panelists.
I'm so excited to talk to you
about emerging markets, why
they matter.
I'm so excited that I've
been up since 4:00 AM today--
had nothing to do with
two screaming kids
at the same time, it's just
pure excitement about the topic.
So I'll just walk
you through a couple
of slides of why we are
particularly excited, as Google
Play, about the emerging markets
before I invite our panelists
to join me on stage.
So if anybody has been
living under a rock,
Android is pretty big.
It's going to be growing quite
a bit over the next few years
as well, external projections
putting it at over 4 billion
in a few years time.
But what we're seeing is that
2/3 of all new Android users
are actually coming
from emerging markets.
So if you are looking at the
next wave of growth for you,
this is where you need to
be, and these are the markets
you need to be investing in.
And you might be thinking,
oh, yeah, that's great,
we'll look at this
in a few years' time.
But the opportunity
is real today.
So for our EMEA-based
developers,
we looked at where are you
getting your installs, what
are the top markets?
And what we found
was three of the four
top markets in which
we're getting installs
are actually emerging markets.
Those are India,
Brazil, and Russia.
And again, you might be
thinking, that's great,
we're getting users.
But do they actually
bring in any money?
And the truth is, they do.
So again, looking at
the top 30 countries
by spend for
EMEA-based developers,
we found that six of
the top 30 countries
are, again, from
emerging markets.
And that's a rate that's
going to continue to go up.
So we're seeing around
60% year on year growth
in spend coming from
emerging markets.
So don't just take it from me.
We have an amazing
set of panelists
who are going to share
their experiences with you.
And hopefully this
will be a discussion
that will get you
excited and leave you
with some ideas of how you
can go after these markets.
First up, we've got Saad,
who's the CEO of Miniclip.
[APPLAUSE]
SAAD CHOUDRI: Hello, everybody.
I've already passed
the first test
because I thought I was going
to stack on those stairs.
Also, thank you, Google.
Let's clap it up for our Google
account managers, everybody.
Let's clap it up, yes?
Let's get the energy up.
Yeah, so we're Miniclip.
One of the games that we're
well-known for is 8 Ball Pool.
It's got a very large audience.
We have 200 million
players every month
engaging with our content.
And one of the areas that we've
been working-- and particularly
with Google-- on
quite strategically
is 8 Ball Pool in India.
It's probably not a
territory that many of you
guys are focusing on.
And the question would
be, is this something
that you should be looking at?
I would say India is just
one of the emerging markets
that you should
be talking about.
Because we will talk
about others in a bit.
But one of the things
that we've definitely
seen in growing our
audience in India
is just the changes
in consumer behavior,
just down to something
so simple as data
plans being far more affordable
for the standard consumer.
Once that started
happening in India,
we saw a massive, massive uptick
in users in that territory.
Because obviously, we've
got a multiplayer game.
And when you've got
a multiplayer game,
it does take up
your data package.
But in India, they
really responded well
to that kind of simple thing.
So we saw a lot of growth there.
And I don't know how much
you want to go into--
around the monetization
techniques.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: [INAUDIBLE]
SAAD CHOUDRI: But we've actually
seen some good monetization
there.
We're in the top-grossing
charts in Android.
You can see it for yourself.
And I would say it's a very,
very meaningful territory
for us, and it's in our top
10 of revenue generators now.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: Fantastic.
Thank you, Saad.
Next up, we have Kristina, who's
a VP of growth for Memrise,
a great language learning.
[APPLAUSE]
KRISTINA NARUSK:
Hello, everyone,
and thank you for
Google for the invite
to share some insights
from Memrise as well.
So Memrise is a
language learning app
with 40 million learners from
more than 180 countries all
around the world.
In terms of emerging
markets, although we
are based in London, in Great
Britain, the emerging markets,
especially Russia,
Poland, Mexico, Brazil,
and even Turkey, are
quite an important part
of our user base growth.
And it would be very exciting to
share some insights and things
that we have done and
experienced in these markets,
in the panel.
It sounds very trivial
and straightforward,
but one of the key
learnings so far
has been that the
more you understand
the markets, the more you
understand the local need
for learning a language,
the better you're
set for a correct
value proposition
and delivering the
promise that people expect
from different countries.
And it can be something
as simple as providing
a US English course instead
of a British English course
for Brazilians.
Or investing in the right
languages to offer Russians.
So small details like that
can make a big difference
and give a lot of guidance to
the product teams and business
as well.
So really excited
to be here today.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: Fantastic.
Thank you, Kristina.
[APPLAUSE]
Next up, it's my pleasure
to introduce Anatolijs,
who's the CEO of Game Insights.
[APPLAUSE]
ANATOLIJS ROPOTOVS:
Thanks, guys.
So we launched Guns of Boom,
by first-person shooter
for Android around
14 months ago.
But the story behind its
launch starts much earlier.
Like two years ago, we
decided to use Turkey, then
Russia, those emerging
markets as a test bath
to validate the game.
And in contrast, the many tier
1 launches, like let's say,
let's try launching in Canada
first, we used those markets,
and we discovered that we have
to support low-end devices.
We have to address loading
speeds, device performance,
data consumptions.
And I think tackling
emerging markets first
has allowed us to enter many
other markets, including India,
Brazil, and other
markets that are growing
at a huge, enormous
pace of millions
of millions of downloads.
So I think the biggest success
behind our presence in Google
Play was that we have integrated
a way for players to upload
their replays to YouTube.
A lot of those emerging markets
have creators and influencers
that are eager to share
the content locally.
And the spread of
that is enormous.
It's thousands and thousands
of daily video uploaded
to YouTube, and the consumption
rate is really high.
The other essential
part is tackling what
we call tier 0 pricing matters.
It's creating the unique value
proposition for as tiny value
as it gets, for the smallest
price tiers out there.
So try that.
Do that.
And if you start
with those markets,
it's going to be much
easier to scale globally.
So this has a couple
of key takeaways.
I guess we'll discuss more.
Thanks to Google.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: Wonderful.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, so one of
the first questions
that we got from developers
is, OK, yeah, emerging markets,
that's great, but
where do we start?
Where do we go to?
For you, what was
the decision factor
to go after these
specific markets
other than a personal interest
in just visiting those markets?
SAAD CHOUDRI: I guess we
saw a lot of user growth
in India because of the
change in the data providers.
And whenever we see users
growing that dramatically,
then you just pay
attention to it naturally.
We've all got our
analytics dashboards.
We can all see what's lighting
up and what's growing.
And so then you just kind of
naturally make that choice.
I have seen, from others
and especially for us
EMEA-based developers, I
tend to think anything that's
close to home is a
little easier as well,
to kind of concentrate on.
But for us, it was the fact
that we saw audience growth
in India, as I'm sure
many people have seen
across other emerging markets.
We've also seen that
growth in Brazil,
which is why we're
concentrating on Brazil as well.
But if you see players
downloading stuff,
then you tend to
kind of see what
you can to try and
further encourage
them to play your games.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: And was
it a similar experience
for you-- follow the
users, basically?
KRISTINA NARUSK: Yes,
Memrise has mostly
grown organically so far.
And I mean, language
learning is something
that people in almost
every single country
tend to and want to do.
And you can focus on so many
different regions and areas.
But for us, one thing was sort
of organic new user numbers
that we obviously monitored.
But a not less
significant factor
was actually
subscriber user base.
So we started
seeing trends where
it was easier for
us to convert people
and to make them
Memrise subscribers.
And we actually
then saw that, OK,
if there is already organic
interest, then what can
we do to actually improve the
value proposition and offering
so that more people
from these countries
have a reason to use our
app and learn languages.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: Fantastic.
ANATOLIJS ROPOTOVS: Well even
though we started with the US
as the global launch
market, we figured out
that, based on the number
of YouTube uploads,
the game resonates well with
a variety of emerging markets.
So we had to tackle that.
We went to Google Play team
to talk about those markets,
went to local Playtime
events, learned more about it,
worked with local creators.
So it was more of a
discovery process--
where do we put
our efforts into?
And especially like
just optimizing
for some of those
markets, it might not
be really as self-explaining.
So it was quite
a learning curve.
But once we got couple of first
countries in, it got easier.
So now I think if we look at
top eight countries, seven
of them--
in terms of monthly downloads--
are emerging countries for us.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: Fantastic.
So you see the user
growth somewhere,
you decide you want
to go after a market.
And typically one of the
things we advise our developers
is to actually localize
for those markets.
But localization can be
a quite broad spectrum,
from just translating
text in-game, all the way
to actually customizing
characters, changing
the in-app experience
for different markets.
How do you decide where do you
want to be on that spectrum?
SAAD CHOUDRI: Well, we
take an approach when
we build the games to try and
reach the biggest audience
possible.
So I mean, for Pool, for
instance, everyone asks us,
what do you do to
culturalize or localize
the game-- apart from strings.
I mean, there's not
much to culturalize
if you think about it.
It's a stick kicking a
ball into a pocket, right?
Like, that's the game.
And if you can't understand
that, don't oversell it.
[LAUGHTER]
But the point is, if you can't
understand that globally,
then that's going to
be a difficult thing.
So I think it's a
bit unfair to ask us.
If you were making an RPG game
or maybe even a shooting game,
it might be a different thing,
in terms of character design
and look and feel.
But for us, what we do
see in localization,
and what we've learned
over the last year is
the things and the
promotions which
tend to be popular
in tier 1 markets
don't necessarily translate
into the emerging markets.
So we've seen-- if you look
at our top in-app purchases
and the top things
that people buy,
it is almost skewed in
India compared to where
it would be in a tier 1 market.
In a tier 1 market, they
would be more open to, say,
a gotcha mechanic, or some sort
of a card pack or something.
Whereas in the
emerging markets, we
tend to find that the hard-nosed
value for soft currency
is what people want.
They want to know exactly
what they're going to get.
That's been our finding.
And therefore, our
localization efforts
means that our promotions
need to cater for that
and what we present
to that audience.
So that's where we
kind of sit on it.
KRISTINA NARUSK: Yes,
we have paid attention
to different phases of the
user acquisition funnel.
So there are things
that you can do
to be a lot more relevant
on Google Play product page
already.
So making sure
that you highlight
things that these people from
the emerging market countries
are really interested in.
You can customize and sort of--
even the selection
of screenshots
that you prioritize to
upload to the Play Store
can teach quite a lot about
what the users appreciates
from these countries.
And even making the
content relevant.
So Memrise offers tens of
language pairs and tens
of languages to learn
for different users.
It's important to understand
what are the top ones.
D Turkish people want to learn
English, German, and Russian?
So there's no point
in prioritizing
Brazilian Portuguese
or Spanish for them
in order to actually
be super relevant.
And then, also, pricing--
I think localized pricing
is something that has really
unlocked opportunities
in different countries,
and where it can make a
big difference whether you
get sort of half a
percentage of people
to pay versus a few
percentages of people to pay.
So there are different
things to look
at, different stages
of the funnel,
and optimization opportunities
almost everywhere.
ANATOLIJS ROPOTOVS: So on our
side, I think back in January
we ran one of the global events,
which was the Lunar New Year.
And it was kind of
counterintuitive
for us, as a local event
that was launched globally,
has performed as
well as Christmas
or something like that
in the US, but globally.
So Lunar New Year was accepted
by everyone across the world.
So since then, every
single local event,
we try to launch it globally,
we try to see how that works.
Like nowadays, like
we recently rolled out
local content for India.
And it was well-received.
And I think it's just because
of that collectible nature
of things inside our game.
People just want
to try all of that,
and they want to have all the
costumes, all of the suits,
and they want to try it all.
So I think it might
work in different ways
for different types of games.
So you have to try
different strategies.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI:
So one of the things
that you obviously know is
that purchasing power varies
between tier 1, mature markets
compared to emerging markets.
How do you cater for that?
How have you thought
about pricing
when you've gone, actually,
after emerging markets?
KRISTINA NARUSK:
So the first thing
we have looked at and
tested quite a bit
as well is to see
what is the sweet spot
for different
subscription plans.
So it's very easy to set
up monthly, three-monthly,
six-monthly, annual plans,
and then see which one works
and how to kind of find that
good spot for the exact price
that has the highest LTV
and long-term potential
for the app.
So there's a lot of ways
how to experiment with that.
We have seen that, in
some emerging markets,
people tend to pick the cheapest
and also the shortest period
subscriptions.
And then thinking of
strategies how to change that,
and how to make the longer plans
either more affordable or more
appealing, and communicating
the right value.
The latest experiment
we did was I
was in Mexico, where we saw that
there is a very high proportion
of users who instead of
going for annual price, which
is the overwhelming
preferred one for Memrise,
70% of people from
Mexico actually picked
the monthly price.
And without doing
anything else but just
increasing the monthly price
subscription fee a little bit,
we see the shift towards people
preferring the annual suddenly.
So just experimenting
around that, and really kind
of understanding the
dynamics and the levers
that you have with the
Google Play tools as well
can get quite
interesting results.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: Anatolijs.
ANATOLIJS ROPOTOVS: Yeah,
for multiplayer games,
it's much harder people.
People in the US might complain
about lower-tier pricing
in the other country.
But we found a sweet spot.
Players might spend
hundreds and sometimes even
thousands of dollars
inside those games.
So we figured out that
giving out the free, kind
of cheaper starter packs, it
be worth tens or even $100.
In some of those
same margin markets,
for much smaller
price, it really
doesn't effect the game play
or game economy that much.
So that's what we opted in for.
We are creating those packs
that might be worth $100 in US,
and we do one-time offers, the
regional offers, and giving
them one time at much,
much lower prices.
And that worked well for us.
It converts the users in
those regions much better.
And it's a great
value for the price.
So you have to find what
you are going to give away,
even for as low as $0.15.
It needs to have the value.
And if you try to
compare that to US price,
it might be just the one
med kit or one ammo pack.
But that doesn't sell
well in emerging market.
You have to create this
whole bundle worth $0.15.
And we are OK with that, because
there is just so much more
things to explore and buy
once they get releases
or seasonal content, or the
[INAUDIBLE] maps, or things
down the road.
So we're totally fine
given the way those bigger
packs initially for
much lower prices.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI:
And with this,
do you not worry about
users from the US
switching over to
emerging markets
and trying to take
advantage of those packs?
ANATOLIJS ROPOTOVS: So
since these are only
starter packs for
new users that you're
able to acquire in
the first weeks,
it's not really a big issue.
It's not like something that
you could get six months
after you play the game.
So that's how we manage
to address this issue.
SAAD CHOUDRI: So OK, I've got
a question for you, Anatolijs.
So what you're saying is, you do
a geopriced starter pack only,
but then afterwards, you
just have standard pricing
across the globe.
ANATOLIJS ROPOTOVS: Well, we do
have some discounts, and deals,
and things like that.
But yeah, well, some of those
deals are kind of still pricey.
So we don't really
adjust the value
of the currency
for those countries
because that's the question.
You can't really do that.
Too many people will try
to switch the region.
Like other platforms
like PC platform
is also dealing with
that, and too many players
are trying to buy the
currency in another region.
So we don't try to do that.
SAAD CHOUDRI: So we did that.
We did a whole
geopricing activity
where we changed
prices completely.
I'm not going to talk
about that question.
We're working with
your team right now
and your Google Play engineers
to try and resolve that.
That's totally an issue.
If you change prices
in one territory,
and you've got a
community, people
will go and try and
game the system.
VPNs are easy to get,
particularly on this platform.
I think we need to
acknowledge that.
But it's too early to tell with
geopricing for us right now.
We definitely saw an
impact in conversion.
We definitely saw
people spend more.
And for us, it wasn't
just a starter pack.
It was across the whole store
and across the whole economy.
And the reality right
now is we're not sure
how that's affected LTV, because
we don't know if people are
doing more purchases,
little and often,
or if they're still
buying the one
pack that they would have done
before, but got more for it.
So we really are still
balancing that thing.
But ultimately, for us, I think
the more important question
is, how much are you getting
in terms of the share of wallet
for that consumer
in that region.
And from what we see in
these emerging markets,
we're very encouraged
by the fact
that they are willing to
spend on entertainment.
The fact that there is a
willingness to spend on IAP,
I think, is a very
interesting thing.
Because I actually think
that emerging markets have
got to that step before
even the tier 1 markets.
I think it took a long time
for free-to-play and IAP game
mechanics to really be seen
as the de facto business
model here in tier 1 markets.
Because if you think about
it, even 5, 10 years ago
we were having debates about,
is free to play the future?
We know it is.
And no one really talks
about that anymore.
But in emerging markets, they
don't even think about it.
They don't worry about it.
So that's where I think
the geopricing stuff needs
to be considered around
the share of wallet
for that consumer.
Because obviously
an Indian consumer
does not have the same
disposable as a US consumer.
But we've seen, in
China, that change.
And obviously you
just have to look
at the kind of macroeconomic
situation of some
of these countries and nations,
that will eventually change.
So we feel like being there
early, making these steps,
and understanding how
the consumer behaves
is super important.
So that's what I'd want to
reinforce in that conversation.
ANATOLIJS ROPOTOVS: I think,
across our games portfolio,
throughout the years,
we've definitely
seen some of the markets
transitioning from emerging
to much more mature markets.
Perhaps southeast
Asian markets that
now have many more
payment [INAUDIBLE],,
and people are just
used to paying that.
So I think it's just
a matter of time
when we will see more spending
power in those countries.
And in a year or
two, we're going
to talk about those
markets not as emerging--
remember that BRICTS had China
in it as an emerging market.
Now we don't speak about China.
So now they call
it still BRITS--
like Brazil, Russia, India,
Turkey, Saudi Arabia.
SAAD CHOUDRI: I've heard of
MINT as well, which is Mexico,
Indonesia, Nigeria and Turkey.
I've have heard
all of them, yeah.
KRISTINA NARUSK:
Yeah, we are seeing
an interesting correlation
between the business
performance of certain
regions and markets
and the deep intention of
people to learn a language.
So an interesting
case has been where
we interviewed a significant
amount of our subscribers
from emerging markets as
well, and then plotted it
against data.
And we saw that, for example,
Russia, and Poland, and Turkey
as well, where people can
learn one level, any language,
for free, and then
have to subscribe.
The speed and the
conversion rate
at very early stages
of user onboarding
was the highest in countries
where the language learning
intention tends
to be sort of less
casual, less a kind of fun,
hobby activity, and more
kind of need, and
sort of aspiration
and professional
improvement related.
And it's quite
fascinating, because it
gives a lot of
insights for product
and then tweaks and improvements
in your onboarding as well.
If you know how to
nail this need versus,
yes, we can match the needs--
correlation.
So it's quite
useful to understand
the behaviors and the
motivators behind users
of apps for these purposes.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: Fantastic.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Can I ask
a question of the crowd?
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI: Yeah.
SAAD CHOUDRI: And if
they're going to engage.
How many of you are
taking active steps
to do something in
emerging markets?
Just one, two, three--
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI:
That's a decent number.
SAAD CHOUDRI: It's
a decent smattering.
But OK, and how many of you--
obviously you're considering it
because you're listening here.
But how many of you think it's
probably a waste of effort
or you don't have the
resources to really attack it?
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI:
You can be honest.
SAAD CHOUDRI: You can be honest.
One-- one person, two, three.
Come on.
There's no more?
OK, all right.
So actually everybody
believes there's effort.
And I think, actually,
the reality of this
is it's not a lot of effort.
It's not a lot of effort.
Because to be honest,
what you guys have
done over the last few
years, I think we--
again, Google has
done a great job.
And it's easy for me to
say this on a Google stage.
But Google has done a
great job in allowing
us to have the
tools to really make
efforts in emerging markets.
So I think if you're
looking to do it,
and you haven't
really done anything--
because a few people haven't--
it's just literally go into
Google Play Developer Console,
and you can start.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI:
That's very true.
SAAD CHOUDRI: I know you're
not allowed to say that,
but it's easy for me to say.
MOHAMMAD EL-SAADI:
Obviously, when I say it,
nobody will believe me.
I'm paid to say it.